[Music]
is
[Music]
is
by the ruderman family foundation which
promotes authentic representation in the
entertainment industry and full
inclusion of people with disabilities
through all all sections of society and
now please welcome academy governors
kate amend
jean chen and roger ross williams
[Applause]
good evening everyone and welcome
this is always a very special night
because we're honoring and celebrating
documentaries
but this year it's even more special
because this is the 20th anniversary of
the creation of our very own documentary
branch in the academy
and do we have any of our original
founders or governors here oh stand up
please freedom
[Applause]
anybody else
thank you we're all
so grateful
well i want to congratulate all our
nominees
you've all made beautiful powerful films
and we all take pride in the work that
you've created
and we're so happy to honor you
we'd like to thank tonight our asl
interpreters jordan lopez and andre lu
lost
for joining us tonight
we'll also have open captions for
tonight's clips in order to make the
show more accessible
now i'd like to introduce my dear friend
and fellow governor roger ross williams
thank you kate um
so it's great to be here so for years i
stood up here and i urged the
documentary branch to sponsor women uh
by poc filmmakers people of color
and um
uh you know we all
all of our hard work has um paid off
because um i'm happy to announce that we
are the most diverse branch in the
academy
let's give your
uh
we've grown to um just over 600 members
and i'm proud of each and every one of
you
over the last few years we've gone from
majority male to majority female
one-third of our branch is international
we've increased our bypoc membership um
immensely
um so um we should all just give
ourselves a great round of applause for
the hard work we've done
um
we're proud of our accomplishments but
um our efforts aren't over our goals um
with the academy aperture 2025
initiative are to are to further the
dialogue and challenge our history to
create a more equitable and inclusive
community
um we will focus on the younger
generation
um like the academy gold program which
uh
gives opportunities to college students
from underrepresented backgrounds
uh and um our uh we have um our academy
women's initiative and our academy
international inclusion initiative
so there's still a lot of work to be
done
uh in the documentary branch we're
facing issues with pipeline for people
of color
so please
if you can
uh sponsor and get an intern of a bypoc
filmmaker as an intern in your company
and really really sort of you know help
us to create new filmmakers
that um that are don't always look like
you know
like like like that looks more like
america
um
i thought i wouldn't be standing here
as your elected leader
i never thought people like me could
have a place at the table
but i was wrong
because people like me belong here asian
black latino queer trans we belong here
representing the academy
uh
i want to
i want to
introduce to you our newest governor
jean chen
jean and i have known each other for
years
she's a very special member of our
branch jean immigrated to the u.s 50
years ago
and eventually she made a name for
herself as an editor of acclaimed
documentarians like barbara koppel
orlando bagwell and our own nominee
stanley nelson
i've had the pleasure of working with
jean
and she's not only a brilliant
storyteller but she brings such joy to
the edit room and to every project she
works on
uh
you know
gene hasn't rested on those laurels
she has spent most of her career
mentoring filmmakers and she was a
mentor to me
so
um please join me in welcoming jean chen
thank you so much
good evening everyone i want to thank
first kate and roger
for your guidance
and your years commitment to the
documentary branch throughout the years
really i also want to thank an unsound
hero i don't know if he's here tom oyer
if you're in the room please stand up
who works tirelessly in holding us
together
this is the 20th anniversary of the
documentary branch and i want to give my
gratitude to all the previous governors
before me
in keeping up with our mission in
connecting the world through cinema
i'm very proud to be part of this great
community yes 50 years ago this month i
immigrated to this country as an 11 year
old
from taiwan
and i never imagined that one day i
would be standing here in this temple of
cinema
as a freshman governor
to welcome each one of you
in 1983
i watched my very first documentary and
it was a 14-minute short
called sewing woman by
arthur dung
the film went on to
be nominated for the 1984 academy award
and it made a great impact on me
it is a testament to the power of
documentary that it does change lives
i'm sure the films that we're
celebrating here tonight
will definitely change someone's life
out there
and for that i congratulate and thank
each one of your nominees for sharing
your beautiful and important work to the
world
and with that we are going to open
tonight's program with the documentary
shorts thank you
[Applause]
please welcome the nominees for audible
matt ogins and jeff mclean
[Applause]
serve audible
matt ogin's director
uh
and prepare a lot it's all riff a bit um
audible's a coming-of-age story
following a deaf high school senior
named amari and his friends and his
family
as he grapples with the pressures of
senior year and and really venturing off
about to venture off into the hearing
world
in many ways it's unique to amari and
the deaf community but it's also
relatable to all of us um
he and anyone who's deaf isn't just
defined by the word deaf they have
relationships and family and tragedy and
sadness and joy
and the film's about many things
representation and inclusion but
underneath it's about belonging
for me it was a 12 years of trying to
get the film made
a lot of knows
people didn't think there was an
audience for this
they'd say it
so
i just kept going i just i
felt there was and spent 12 years the
coach in my film when i first started
was supposed to be my main character and
was on the football team that's how long
it took
and i grew up about 30 minutes away and
i think my deepest connection is my best
friend is deaf since i was about seven
so in a way for me it was a way to
uh connect and understand him more and
then i met jeff my producer and fellow
nominee and maybe there's no
coincidences his best friend growing up
in toronto is death
um
and so just all these things lined up
and so
uh
yeah
i i think we all want to be in a world
where we understand each other's stories
um
i'm grateful to be in this room with all
of you storytellers uh
building those connections and
you all have been my teachers um yeah
yeah like matt said i just the the deaf
community has been extremely welcoming
to the two of us since we were young and
when we were shooting this film the msd
community was was
extremely welcoming and let us get
as involved as we wanted to and it's
just been an honor to be a part of
telling their story with this film
and just to set up this clip um
rather than making like an observational
film where we were on the outside
looking in we spent a lot of time way
before we filmed trying to make like an
immersive
audio visual experience that felt like
it was
um
amari who made the film and we were just
conduits to create a safe space for them
to tell their story so hopefully you see
that in in this clip
thank you
hmm
wow
[Applause]
[Music]
um
um
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
okay
[Music]
everybody
[Applause]
please welcome the nominees for lead me
home pedro coss and john shank
[Applause]
wow that was beautiful um
hello good evening um
we are so
feeling so fortunate to be here so
grateful to be here
in the company of so much amazing talent
lead me home
started in 2017
my wife and filmmaking partner and
producer of this film bonnie cohen
turned to pedro me one day and said you
know
there's a giant crisis of um
humanity going on in our city of san
francisco
and in los angeles and in seattle and
portland
up and down the west coast
and um
we started talking about it and the the
the
immediate thought that came into i think
all of our head is that
there's this kind of tension that exists
i think among all of us who who live in
in these cities in america right now
which is that we are
constantly overwhelmed
by the fact that hundreds of thousands
of us
are falling out of the modern economy
that we have in this country um
whether it's due to uh
rent uh going up or a medical bill
that's unexpected
or
a job that's lost
and we i think many of us who are
sensitive feeling people naturally
you know feel that and and have
compassion for our neighbors and yet the
other side of it is that we all
go about our business every day
going to work um school
restaurants cafes meetings
kind of busy and
we have to turn off that part of our
brain to ignore that giant crisis that's
going on all around us so that's where
it started um to
sort of in a way kind of
do a 180
of that of that way of thinking and to
try to look at this in the face and um
[Music]
that's when pedro and i started working
together and um it was such a joy and um
turn it over to pedro to tell you a
little bit about some of the creative
thoughts we had about getting that done
and uh
it was first of all was a magical
transformative process for
for not only john and i but for the
entire team especially sarah marshall
who's here um our amazing other amazing
producer
and we
we wanted to capture not only the scale
but sort of the
shift perspective and look
at our own cities our own lives
from a perspective that we've been
marginalizing and making invisible for
too long
and really
anchoring in the extraordinary people
our neighbors
who are experiencing homelessness
and
we we set out we met with
a lot of organizations city officials
and
we began to meet people and we actually
say that the the the people that you get
to meet in the film chose
chose us chose to uh share their stories
their lives
and
the um
the the clip that you're about to see
tonight
is a
a little section of the of the film
where
um
the film is an experiential uh
experience to
to
basically to show that there's so much
more that unites us than separates us
and this
evening time montage that we like to
call is um
you will get to meet and see the
beautiful artistry of ronnie futuristic
willis who's here tonight
um
ronnie
stand up
um
ronnie
and
you get to see that we all have
um there's so much to unite us there's
we're incredible artists we
gather with our families we dream and we
love
and
this is um this is a little moment from
that film
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
dreams
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
here
[Music]
where do you usually sleep
um
[Music]
and
kept going like that
uh have you been attacked or beaten up
since you've become homeless
recently i've been in
day four right okay
please welcome the nominee for the queen
of basketball ben proudfoot
[Applause]
that was beautiful john and pedro
um
good evening
how's everybody doing tonight
good
thanks for coming out to support
documentaries
uh it's an absolute honor to be here and
have the opportunity to speak to you all
this evening
in this hallowed place
with
such incredibly esteemed colleagues
thank you to the academy the documentary
branch governors for having us
i just want to acknowledge the the
members
some members of our team
that made the film with me they've
joined
here tonight as well
uh thank you for coming thank you for
all you did yes please give them round
of applause
all of our films we
uh
our teams are here my mom is here
somewhere um so i'm ben
in our film the queen of basketball
chronos chronicles the incredible life
story
of the late ms lucy harris
a towering
pioneer in the game of basketball
who was denied the opportunity
and exposure
her male counterparts received
because of her gender
and the color of her skin
you'll get to meet her and hear a bit of
her story in a moment
i could speak at length about miss
harris and her unbelievable legacy
but she can speak very well for herself
and so i invite you instead to watch the
entire film when you get a chance it's
22 minutes and it's on youtube
for free
and instead today as a very grateful
guest in the academy's house cinema's
house
i'd like to take this chance to
celebrate
the short documentary
people assume that short documentarians
are featured documentarians without the
budget
not for me the short documentary is
actually my art form of choice
and i'm very proud of it
i've been lucky enough
to have been nominated in this category
two years in a row now and after
spending a decade building a short
documentary company the truth is the
short documentary has very few advocates
it's nearly impossible to make money
making short documentaries
and so it's always seen as a calling
card category for filmmakers a stepping
stone
art form
on the way to making
real movies
well i think that's selling the format
short
a short documentary is a real movie
i think these five films
are real movies great movies in fact i
believe the short documentary is
actually the most exciting corner of
cinema
and i think it's the future of cinema
and i'll tell you why
we all accept that the more of a
meritocracy our industry is the more it
will thrive
but the biggest obstacle to
opportunities for filmmakers is how
incredibly expensive it is to make and
distribute a film
and we must grapple with the influence
that money has on the documentary
we should not accept as artists and
activists that cinema is to be used
simply to accumulate app subscribers and
bolster share prices
cinema especially documentary cinema
is a business yes that we all
participate in but it should be about
documenting our common human experience
should be about expanding human
imagination
should be about giving voice where there
has been silence
about filling in the illusions in
history and offering unimaginable
visions for the future
it's about using stories to expand the
human heart and mind and set the spirit
free
and we need that force
from everywhere and everyone in today's
world
the best kept secret in cinema is that
the short documentary is the most timely
and democratic form of cinema
it has the lowest barrier of entry to
finance and make
it has the lowest barrier of entry to
watch
you know our film is 20 minutes long
it's available for free
short documentary is where you will find
the highest ratio
of investment to impact and audience
size
a 50 000 short documentary can have as
big of an audience and as big of an
impact on the public consciousness as a
hundred million dollar feature
film and important stories with little
commercial promise
actually can get made
as short docks
frankly if the queen of basketball was a
feature film i'd probably be still
raising the
money and miss harris would be gone
and her story with her
it is the most democratic form of cinema
and i believe that's why the short
documentary will become the most diverse
the youngest and the most international
form of cinema
it will also become the most widely
watched form of cinema that's already
happening
because great stories find a way
storytellers with great stories find a
way as you've seen and we'll see
and the internet and our phones will
take care of the rest
the mona lisa is about yea big
one frame
and i look forward to the day when this
cat category is chock full
of mona lisas from every corner of the
planet
i love making and watching future
documentaries
and i have utmost respect for that form
as well
the people in this room have beckoned in
a golden age for documentary and even
changed our idea of what a documentary
can be
but our form the short documentary
desperately needs advocating too
and i'm here to assert that there's
nothing small or less
about short
i learned that from my mother
five three and a half there she is
wonderful lady
[Applause]
so i stand proud
as a short documentarian
among these consummate and elegant films
and filmmakers
i am grateful to the academy
for being the world's greatest champion
of the form
i believe it is a most wise investment
and now i'm proud to present a clip from
our short documentary
the queen of basketball long live the
queen thank you
their main weapon is number 45 lucia
harris
always a dominating inside force
her scoring and rebounding is a must if
delta is to claim its second straight
national title
[Applause]
[Music]
nobody expected us to win back-to-back
championships an intense rivalry is
built up between delta and evaculana
and tonight's game has national
supremacy on the line
so we won
now the championship trophy to margaret
wade and her dallas state lady statesman
this year's tournament has been an
outstanding success
[Music]
cleveland
a peaceful community in the heart of the
mississippi delta a town of friendly
people rich agriculture and the lady
statesman basketball team of delta state
university twice national champs after
only four years of existence as a team
and i look up to lucy because she's like
the greatest woman player that's ever
been and to me you know that's something
really great i think she
she's special because
she can do about anything
she drives she rebounds she jumps she
blocks shots
she's tough
lucy well she's hard to describe really
she's
like one in a million i don't think
they'll ever be another ball player like
her and to have the personality that she
has and be as humble as she is
it's really incredible it's hard to
explain
well attention you know to me is saying
that a lot of people are interested in
what we're doing you know and they're
keeping up with it and i think that's
good
[Music]
montreal
that was the very first time that
women's basketball was placed in the
olympics
it was just unreal
[Music]
we played japan the very first games
they shot the first basket
but they missed
came back down the court
and myers passed me the ball i shot it
and made it
that was the first basket in the history
of olympic rhythm basketball
and ann meyer said
that's history
i said oh yeah
maybe that is history
[Music]
now that's a record they'll never be
broken
lucia harris
[Applause]
we want a silver medal
i
wanted my parents to be proud of me
and they were
make you feel special
the center for delta state a 6-3 senior
from mentor city mississippi co-captain
number 45 lucy harris
delta state has won its third
consecutive
aiaw national basketball championship
[Music]
i really have enjoyed myself you know
being
you know playing on the last uh
intercollegiate basketball team that i
will play on
and uh we really appreciate what all of
you have done thank you
i wanted to keep playing
but there was no place to go
there was no wnba
when i came along
didn't exist
welcome the nominees for three songs for
benazir elizabeth mirzae and gulistan
mirzay
[Applause]
all right
hello everyone
i'm golov
i'm from afghanistan
it's really amazing to be standing here
at the first time
direct from afghanistan
every nominate for an oscar
this is a historical moment and all that
means
as i look
at all of you tonight
it gives me
great hope that a small history about my
country and my people
could be a bring
bridge on which i am standing right now
communicate with all of you
both in person and through the first
film
and thank you
from for having me
it is really such an honor for both of
us to be here as golesan's wife and also
the co-director of this film
um what golosan said reminds me of a
realization that dawned on me during the
making of three songs from benazir
it reminded me of a moment that we were
inside the camp in kabul camp for people
displaced by the war and we were in
shaista and benazir's house
and there was a military helicopter
whirring overhead it was really the only
sign of the world outside and the war
and shaista just broke out into this
love song for bennett's year
and
it was funny it was sweet it was tender
i was trying not to laugh and the camera
was shaking
and in that moment something shifted and
we realized that this really isn't a
film about a young man recruit being
recruited into the afghan national army
it's about a young couple who are in
love and it's about the promise to stand
by your partner no matter what happens
in life
i'm from right outside philadelphia i
moved to afghanistan i learned the
language gulas and i began making films
together
i fell in love with the country and
immersed myself in it for over eight
years
and in that time we worked together and
we looked at war and all the costs of
war the costs that both can and cannot
be calculated
the costs that are both visible and
invisible
at poverty at the concept of the enemy
and how that idea changes and shifts
but what we didn't expect and what i'm
so grateful for as we got deeper into
the lives of shaistan benazir
is that we'd be making a film as much
about ourselves as it was about the
supposed other you know we were falling
in love as they were falling in love we
got married as they got married we were
building a family as they were building
a family
and i'm convinced that the films the
best films that resonate with us
and the bar that we aspire to is the one
that binds us all on some of the
universals no matter the particulars
thank you
oh
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
please welcome the nominee for when we
were bullies jay rosenblatt
[Applause]
hi everybody
well it's quite an honor to be here
tonight
and a real honor to be with my fellow
nominees who all have made very
beautiful films
um
ben i think i could be the poster child
for your film movement of short docs
since that's all i've been doing for 30
years
and um thank you
and you touched upon this but what i'd
like to just add is
don't give up your day job
so
my film is um
i want to talk about
coincidence for a few minutes
albert einstein
said
coincidence is god's way of remaining
anonymous
and i feel like that's what happened
with this film that was the root of this
film
it starts with a
mind-boggling coincidence i'm not going
to go through it all because it's in the
film hopefully you've seen it or will
see it
and it's it's quite involved but it's
pretty it's like lottery odds
but
um when i was telling this story to a
friend six years ago and this was my
favorite story i would tell this at film
festivals or if i did like a master
class i would tell this story this
coincidence i told it to a friend about
six years ago and she said you know you
should make a film about that
and i thought yeah maybe i should
so um
i
decided to search for my classmates from
fifth grade to see what they remembered
from a bullying incident
over 50 years ago
but
i didn't know how i would tell this
story because i did not want to rely on
talking heads
and i'm kind of more of a b-roll guy
so um
i knew i would use some film footage
because i kind of make collage films and
that's what i've done
but i wanted to do something different
and i thought
maybe i'll work with an animator maybe
i'll do some animation
so
there was one person i knew
and uh he's here tonight
and he was my
daughters and my daughter is here
tonight too
he was my daughter's
after school teacher
and then he gave her guitar lessons
and
after one lesson
somehow it came out that he did short
animations
and
um
i asked if i could see some of them and
he gave me links and they're really
beautiful short films that he
writes the music for and sings
his name is jeremy rourke
and
i'm telling you this because
if
my daughter didn't take guitar lessons
from him
i honestly don't think i'd be standing
here right now because his animation is
so wonderful and such an integral part
of my film
that um
i think that's a big part of why i'm
here
so
when we began working together and we
worked together probably two and a half
to three years back and forth he did
analog animation which is
frame by frame not computer animation
it's very time consuming he goes into
his own
and sometimes he go into that zone for a
few months before i get some images to
play with
and we went back and forth and we came
to one
decision
together he has different styles of
animation but particularly i like this
um cutout animation
and um
i think the kind of uh
inspiration for this was i was looking
at the class photo and i i thought you
know what
we should just use this photo and think
of every permutation we could possibly
think of a lot of times when you create
these kind of limits
more creativity comes out if you can do
a film about anything without any limits
it's very difficult
so these cutouts really fit my aesthetic
this collage aesthetic
and
the elements aside from the animation
are some
interviews
mainly phone interviews some found
footage like i said there's some live
action
the biggest challenge was getting the
right tone
in this film
which
was both serious and playful
with a bit of a detective story feel
and i think in the clip you're going to
see
you'll see all those elements
play off of each other
and the last thing i want to say is my
film's about 10 year olds
being bullies
and or being complicit
but as we're well aware
we have one wreaking havoc in the world
right now
one big bully
and we had one
for four horrible years here
so
unfortunately
my film is very timely
i hope you enjoyed the clip thank you
[Applause]
participated
oh yeah
one last thing
we got caught
richard remembered details i had
completely forgotten or maybe i just
blocked
like how mrs bromberg would insist that
we were totally silent and sit at
attention with our hands clasped before
she would let us go home
but on this particular day it was
different
mrs bromberg
ran a tight ship
and she wasn't going to put up with
nonsense i you know so when she says
no one's leaving
i want it absolutely silent
and i will decide when you leave
and we all just gonna go
[Music]
and it's taking a long time you know
usually that's about a minute you know
as a teacher myself i know you just you
want to make a minute and then you go
it's going on and on and on and finally
she says you can go you would have left
earlier but richard
was talking
i was outraged i wasn't talking
and then i
realized
people thought it was me and i i was
gonna get [ __ ] for it i didn't want
people being mad at me
so we pack up our stuff
and it occurs to me
that
it must have been the other richard in
the class who we called dick
that was his name that he was assigned
in fourth grade when there were four
richards
in the same class in mrs weedman's class
it was richard i was richie there was a
rich
and then this other guy got dick
and you know in the hierarchy of
fourth and fifth grade
that's not a good thing
yeah so
as we're packing up our stuff
i started i passed along to michael
sorrell who was right in front of me i
said
it was dick
get dick
pass it down and started getting passed
down
all the way down the line as we were
walking down
and
everybody heard it and as we get out of
the building
we he's he must have heard it as well
because he starts running but we all as
a mess kept on running down the stairs
and surrounded him and
jumped on him i jumped on him and
michael sorrell jumped on him that's
what i remember the most
girls were jumping on him it was like
out of control
but we were all angry at him
now let's pick up where we left off
at the lock gate of ps194
god
i don't like this
i don't know where to put my foot uh if
you can get that foot down
and then just the other foot over
then if you can move your hands to the
fence at some point
don't come down fast
[Music]
it's almost as if you can almost see the
spot you know it just
feels like it was right here
there's there's something right here and
this is where we surrounded him
and some kids spit on him everybody's
taunting him with uh
whatever everybody wanted to do it
seemed it seemed like everybody had free
will to uh
to to do whatever it felt like he
deserved and this is where i remember at
this point being a bit of an instigator
and i remember being on my knees
somehow and then
seeing looking back we're here so
perhaps i was punching him perhaps just
spitting on just perhaps yelling i don't
remember the specifics of what i did but
i do know michael sorrell another
student was uh next to me because
everybody stops and we look up and we
see coming down the stairs mrs bromberg
and dr pink is the principal
everybody gets up as one and starts
running and running then i remember the
next day
coming in
and mrs bromberg sent
dick out
for an errand and then just turned to
the class and just said you are animals
and really gave us
a going to yeah
so
it's just
so i you know from my perspective it was
like
i was trying to keep
me from getting
the wrath of the class and pinned it on
him
this experience that clearly affected us
both
and the more i delve into it
the more upset i am that i was involved
and as i was soon to learn
we were not alone in this memory
please welcome back to the stage kate
amend
[Applause]
wow those are really
inspiring
so now we're going to meet the
filmmakers
who were nominated for best documentary
feature
but first i would like to share some
thoughts
from a beloved documentary filmmaker
that we lost this week
mourinho goldavskaya
this is from her book
woman with a movie camera
work on a movie gives rise to so many
unexpected events and turns
all kinds of circumstances demanding
demanding enormous spiritual energy
it is simultaneously so exhausting and
so attractive
that i don't know of anything else that
brings such joy
i have become addicted
it's a strange profession
i never know where it will lead me
i have to be prepared for the most
unexpected changes
and not get lost
not be afraid
and not give up
so now let's meet some filmmakers who
were not afraid
did not get lost
and did not give up
[Applause]
please welcome
the nominees for ascension jessica
kingdon kyra simon kennedy and nathan
truesdell
[Applause]
hi everyone
i'm jessica kington the director of
ascension
i'm curious simon kennedy the producer
of ascension
and i'm nate trousdale the producer of
ascension also
um
thanks for the to the academy for
hosting us and having this awesome event
it's really fun to be able to see the
clips and talk about different stories
related to them so
yeah i really appreciate the opportunity
to do that and
it's just a huge honor to be part of
this documentary community that's
clearly thriving and i just feel lucky
to be part of it
so ascension is an observational film
that is loosely about the chinese dream
in vignettes it's a study of upward
mobility through the industrial supply
chain that is about china as much as it
is about america
i'm going to talk about the back story
of the clip that you're going to see up
here
one of the locations that i wanted to
shoot at was at a trump hat factory
this was 2018 right at the beginning of
his re-election campaign
my co-producer maggie lee who's in the
audience here
she can stand up if she wants
um
she
maggie uh cold called several factories
for me to to try to get us into a maga
hat factory and one of them let us in
set in iwu
iwou is a major city of manufacturing
and shipping
the owner named hunter was initially
reluctant skeptical of us believing us
to be scammers
this was quite common factory owners
often suspected us of trying to get some
sort of cash out of them for appearing
in our film
but hunter decided to take a chance on
us anyway and
as soon as we showed up he warmed up to
us and realized that we weren't trying
to get money from him
but um he had some bad news for us his
factory was fresh out of mega hats due
to a large order that had just been
placed from all of all places from
canada
um
however he said that they were making
trump scarves and so i said sure you
know i'll i'll film that
so as i'm shooting the scarf the
embroidery i see the slogan start to
emerge and it says keep america great
instead of what i was anticipating make
america great again
i thought that it was some kind of error
a mistranslation perhaps
but they told me no that is trump's
reelection campaign slogan and that was
where i first encountered it
it's said that business people in iwo
are ahead of the curve when it comes to
global trends even predicting election
outcomes
because they're the wholesale
distributors of the world the so-called
commodity city of the world
they tend to know things before the
public does
people in iwo were predicting while we
were there people in iwo were predicting
trump would be our new president and
luckily this time they were wrong
um
so maggie
can applause for that
um
maggie befriended the factory owner
hunter they're still in touch in close
touch to this day
and they're going into business together
now manufacturing these colorful condom
bags that you may have seen her wear
it should be no surprise to all of you
that hunter is no trump supporter
um this sequence was meant to feel like
a collage of factories that's meant to
be a journey through production
processes where one factory blends into
the next
the sequence ends in a sextile factory
that produces ai dolls a large portion
of which end up here in the states
this part never made it into the film
but i wanted to tell you this story
because it's just too good not to tell
um we actually interviewed one of the
dolls when we found out that they could
have conversations
the
the it was nate's idea to interview i
wouldn't have thought about that um
the manager the manager told us i'm
sorry that wasn't supposed to be any i
was trying to give him credit not
okay
so the manager um the manager told us
the dolls were bilingual in both english
and mandarin
so we conducted an interview in both
however during the english conversation
the doll kept steering us back to the
topic of what life is like in the north
pole and whether or not we had completed
some sort of list
we asked the engineer about why the
english persona was so limited in
comparison to the mandarin persona
they were puzzled the people at this
factory spoke little english so they
weren't aware that they had actually
purchased a database that had the
personality of a santa claus
i sometimes like to imagine the shock of
a customer as he tries to converse with
his doll
every location that we went to had a
kind of backstory like this it's i've
heard the phrase kind of like shadow
film that happens behind an actual film
that you see on screen so every location
had something like this um and we just
had so much fun doing it being able to
make this film was the adventure and
privilege of my lifetime and i'm so
thankful to everyone who helped me craft
this vision of china my producers nate
and kira obviously who were here from
the very beginning and without their
support i never would have been able to
go through with it even when it was so
hard to articulate and it seemed so
improbable
um people in the audience my associate
producer and xiaomina and our executive
producers at xtr and of course maggie
this vision of the us and china where
the two are inextricably linked
as you'll see in these clips below
beneath
above thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
funny
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
please welcome the nominees for attica
stanley nelson and tracy a curry
[Applause]
hey thank you it's so great to uh be
here um
first i i just want to say you know
we're sitting over here right in this
place and doesn't it look like this
statue is a black man with a short afro
like right
[Applause]
thank you doc branch
um
i think that that in starting on on
attica
i kind of knew how how it ended
um
but that's the only thing i knew i knew
how the story ended
and
i really wanted to try to figure out
how it got there and and how it ended
like that and and that's really what i
think started
us down the road of making this film um
i was thinking about how um
you know as filmmakers
um we also have been on this journey and
and it's ended up here and
um uh you know we all know how it how it
ends so far you know that that we're
nominated for an academy award which is
incredible and fantastic
um
and so we kind of know how the story
ends in in in some ways similar to
our journey with attica
um
one of the things that that uh
we knew from the beginning was that
there was some footage of of the
rebellion and what happened in in the
prison
we had no idea that there was the amount
of footage that we ended up finding
and kind of miraculously we found
for some reason
the prison the prison guards at the
prison
had one of the first
iterations of home video and so
they were filming from the very
beginning as the riot actually broke out
and up in the tower they were filming in
black and white for the whole five days
and then the prisoners when they took
over the prison of attica
[Music]
they immediately invited the press in
because they thought if the press came
in and filmed and made it transparent
that they would then
uh in some way have some kind of
protection
so
um
there was just incredible amount of
footage and then we started to to find
these great people
um to talk about uh what had happened in
the event
um tracy you want to talk a little bit
about that uh
sure i was going to say something else
but yeah
whatever you want sorry i didn't know
that i was going to be speaking tonight
so i did not prepare anything um
i i was talking to someone earlier this
evening um about all of the amazing
films that we were so honored to um
share this category with and um as
different as they all are
what has occurred to me um in watching
all of them is that there's this thread
that runs throughout all of these films
in which
the films demand that you recognize the
humanity and the personhood of people
that we often
don't see and don't hear
and who it's easy to
to overlook
and i think that the the ability that
this medium allows to do that is really
what compels us as filmmakers to do this
work
um when we started out with attica it
occurred to me that it would be a tall
order for us in that regard because in
some ways prisoners are the people that
it's easiest for us to dismiss
to dehumanize to not hear to not see
and so
i was a little concerned
about whether or not audiences would
really be able to connect to these
people and
i'm so grateful that we are standing
here as a testament to the fact that
viewers did do that
for this film so
the clip that i believe you're about to
see this evening is one that does insist
upon
that recognition from the audience in
ways that are
brutal that are maddening infuriating um
but in a way that i think that you can't
forget and that doesn't let you go so
so just to set up the
clip a little more um after uh
the prisoners took over the prison of uh
of attica they held it for five days
um and um after five days the uh
law enforcement was threatening to come
in
and this is kind of the culmination of
of the of the rebellion as
um
law enforcement comes to take back the
prison with
just an incredible uh force so this is i
think the beginning of the last day
of the five-day
attica rebellion
[Applause]
we are not advocating violence
we all
want to live
all of us
if any of you gentlemen own dogs
you're treating them better than we have
been treated
they were fiercely
trying to convince prison authorities
that they didn't cease being a human
being merely by the fact that they were
incarcerated because they had broken
a law of society
and that's a profound thing
i am somebody
i'm not a thing
you can't treat me like a dog
i may be a prisoner but i have dignity
and that's what they insisted
on getting the
power structure
of attica to recognize
that they continue to be
somebody
the observers they all
were listening to us
i feel
that they were supporting us
you see and
that meant a lot to us
this is our situation please listen to
us and that's what they were doing they
were listening it felt like there was
somebody that believed in us it felt
that way
did somebody believe that you know you
did have some rights even though you
were a convicted felon or whatever
would we able to get
better mailing privileges
better medical privileges we tried to
nail it down to that which was
realistic
and possible
i was distinguished from
a plane waiting for us
outside the cell block flying us to cuba
that's what it was it was
it was realism
from
fantasy
we want to be treated as human beings
we will be treated as human beings
we have come to the conclusion
after close study
after much suffering
after much consideration
that if we cannot live
as people
then we will at least try
to die like men
that statement was sounded
everywhere
in that yard when he said that aurora
went up
like no other this was a stand
i saw that
uh i really none of us were going to be
observers we were going to be mediators
whether we wanted to be mediators or not
whether we were called up to be
mediators
this
prison uprising had to be mediated
otherwise it was going to end in
disaster
if you people
do not understand
if you people do not stick with us
if you people cannot make the commitment
that we have made here
we are dead
i
appeal we teach you all
to stand with us
watch us
play with us if
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and all the necessary
[Applause]
please welcome three of the nominees for
flea giannis poyo rasmussen monica
hellstrom
cine byro sorensen
[Applause]
um my name is john wasser rasmussen and
i'm the director of flea and it's
really wonderful to be here all the way
from
from
copenhagen denmark
do you want to introduce yourself
i'm one of the producers my name is
monica hellstrom
and i'm
one of the other producers senior bureau
sanction
and then we have our third
producer she's not here today she's
jealous
of the animation producer
so so flea is an animated documentary
about a very dear friend of mine
this guy uh who showed up in my
sleepy danish hometown um
when i was 15 25 years ago
and he came all by himself from
afghanistan
and stayed in foster care with a family
just around the corner from from where i
lived
and we started meeting up at the bus
stop every morning going to high school
and
slowly became very good friends
and i was of course already back then
curious about how and why he had come
but he didn't want to talk about it
and i of course respected that and you
know being a 15 year old boy you're like
okay sure let's just hang out
and so we did but this story of his past
kind of became this
black box in our friendship um and also
within him
that he couldn't open
until nine years ago um
i had been invited for this workshop in
denmark called called any docs where
they invite animators and documentary
filmmakers to develop ideas for animated
documentaries
and they asked me if i had an idea
and i thought that this might be a good
way to
jai started to tell his story and and
we met up and i asked him and
he had a growing
urge to share his story because he felt
this disconnect in his life that he
couldn't make his past and president
connect
and he felt a need to share his story
and he was really intrigued by the fact
that he could be anonymous behind the
animation because
what you see in the film what you hear
in the film is his real voice
telling his story for the very first
time and it's not easy for him to talk
about it's his life traumas
um and he couldn't be public about these
things he didn't want to be the public
guy
because he can't small talk about this
you know he wouldn't
you know he didn't want to be able to
go to work and then meet people who
would then want to talk about uh his
traumas or meet people in the
supermarket
um
so the fact that he could be anonymous
was what enabled him to stop sharing his
story
and what was enabled him to start
opening up about his past and connecting
his past and present
and
so
making an animated documentary film was
a
groundbreaking first we've never worked
with animation before come from
documentary and it was a really exciting
and a heartfelt project that to meet
and couple up with this animation
company and try and develop something
that we'd not done before they didn't
understand the language of documentary
we didn't understand the language of
animation
and for some reason this is like
we kind of joke about it as a bumblebee
that we try to make fly and that's why
we're so proud to be here today we are
nominated in three categories but
being in the doc brands we belong here
and we're so proud to stand next to
these four other incredible strong films
that all have such important methods in
their heart and i think this is
this is where we belong and we're very
proud to be among these films
with strong messages that we want to
share and to make a better world for
people around us
thanks
i think flea
is very much a story about collaboration
both like monica said between animate
the the world of animation and and
documentary
but also it's it's a in many ways a
typical story about european
co-production what makes us
makes it possible for us in a small
country like denmark to make a film like
this
which
we have to say is a very expensive
documentary film but a very cheap
animation film
um
is
that we we are so lucky that we have um
public service television stations in in
europe like uh
for example in france germany and we
have uh public funding uh through film
institutes like the danish film
institute
the norwegian film institute the swedish
film institute that we can access to
co-producers and on this project we have
had fantastic co-producers
in denmark we have besides final cut for
real where we come from we have had sun
creatures the animation company and then
in france we have had bim among lundi
and in norway and sweden mere film and
most film
and without this whole sort of
big uh collaboration around a project
like this
it wouldn't have been possible so
we really want to thank all these
collaborators and then i should also say
that
one thing is making the film that's
that's hard enough as you all in this
room you you all know
but uh bringing it out to the audience
is is also a huge part of of making a
film like this and for that we are
extremely grateful to
nian in the us and to participant who
have helped us bring it and twice who
have helped us bring it out to the
audiences here and also to all the other
distributors around the world who have
embraced the film and make
made it a public conversation about
people
the refugee experience and not not just
that people are refugees but that being
a refugee is something that you may
experience but you are also a lot of
other stuff around it like you see with
emin
and his life as
as an academic as a cat lover as eunice
likes to say and
that that story comes out to all these
audience who right now in this world
are
that we hope that they will also embrace
all the refugees that are still coming
out of afghanistan syria ukraine and and
places that our experiences were like
that thank you
and just to
introduce the clip um
well first of all you know
it's called flea and it is about the
fiscal flight going from afghanistan to
denmark and it's it is a refugee story
but it's really a story about home and
belonging and connectivity it's about
amin who is
a refugee and also gay and who for all
of his life has had to
hide past himself
when he was kid in afghanistan he
couldn't be openly gay when he arrived
in denmark he couldn't be honest to his
past
so all this life he's had to
hide um so this film is about a man
looking for a place in the world where
he feels he can be who he is
with everything that entails and the
clip you're going to see now is from our
very first conversations when he started
to open this black box it was in my home
in copenhagen nine years ago
yeah
thank you
[Applause]
oh
it
mm
[Music]
[Music]
be
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
to
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
please welcome two of the nominees for
summer of seoul or when the revolution
could not be televised robert fiveland
and david dinnerstein
[Applause]
thank you guys um
first i want to say just you know what
an honor it is
to be nominated with these films and uh
it's just been an incredible experience
um we also wanted to um
say that quest love couldn't be here
tonight
uh our third producer joseph patel uh
also couldn't be here but
part of the
um
[Music]
sort of joy of the experience of working
on this film
was seeing quest love emerge as an
important new voice in
the documentary film world and
you know we're happy to have been a part
of that
um
i started on this film 15 years ago
i
flew to bronxville new york
and
convinced hal tolchin who had shot the
original footage
that
he should let me make a documentary
and i convinced him we'd build the right
team
um and we did
um and
you know for 15 years i kept
reminding him or you know convincing him
you know we'll get this we'll get this
done and
there were you know many times or
several times over that uh period of
time that the film almost got made and
um
you know we just couldn't get it over
the finish line and i i tell people all
the time thank god it it didn't happen
at any of those other times because this
was the right team and the right way to
tell the story
and
it's the right time in the country for
the story i i think and
i think people needed the joy
of and the celebration of this movie
coming out of the pandemic
and
so from that perspective
you know i'm happy that that this is the
version of the movie that got made
um i'll let david tell you a little bit
about the the clip that we're going to
see
sure uh before we do that i just wanted
to sort of thank the academy it's really
such a privilege to be in this beautiful
space
to watch all of these clips on this
amazing screen with this great sound uh
it's such an honor and i also wanted to
acknowledge uh two of our eps that are
in the house tonight and they just
provided just unbelievable of support
and that's marie therese girgis and
janet gargey
so thank you guys stan please
acknowledge yourselves
i also
you know just wanted to acknowledge and
i'll do this for robert too i wanted to
acknowledge my wife
allison who you know has been
watching me and and my wife brittany
and they've been watching us you know
i've been on this film for roughly six
years with robert and uh
they've been watching us just you know
continue to push the rock up the hill
and i just wanted to say the patience
they have to be able to listen to this
wonderful soundtrack to summer of soul
on a constant loop for the past six
years is really your patience is amazing
so thank you thank you thank you uh
you know this movie
started out
as a dream that hal tulchin and tony
lawrence had uh
they wanted to
really throw this epic event to heal a
community that is often a maligned
and it was
you know
an event that took place
within the same
you know month that this iconic event
100 miles away took place as well
the
difference was the harlem cultural
festival was largely forgotten by most
and it has really taken sort of this
this effort
you know to be able to sort of
take this erased piece of history and
try and do our best to reclaim it to
bring it to a community to honor them
and the clip you're going to see tonight
is really
something that quest love was very very
much attuned to uh as a drummer he
always felt that he wanted to start a
clip with a 19
year old stevie wonder who
you know very few people knew was you
know and a badass on the drums uh
and it was sort of a cold open to a film
and
you could just see the audience and sort
of uh
you know the attention they were giving
this young 19
years year old at the time that was
about to emerge into the stevie that we
know today
uh
the harlem cultural festival took place
over six
sundays in 1969 uh hal tolchin uh had
the ability to hire you know a crew he
used four cameras to document the
performances
uh
we were able to work with 40 hours of
archival
performance foot
footage but i also wanted to acknowledge
uh
our archivist lizzie mcglynn who went
you know so far beyond you know what any
archivist has the ability to do she dug
deep
and you know worked with our editor josh
pearson to put together scenes in this
movie that you may not see tonight but
hopefully you'll be able to either watch
this film or you have watched it but
pivotal scenes like the moon landing the
death of dr king
you know and so many other amazing
scenes and she scoured the archives
in
new york in los angeles all through the
world to find footage that would help
contextualize the story quest love and
our team wanted to tell
so uh the clip you'll see tonight
is really the beginning of the film
and it will sort of introduce you and
hopefully you know get to uh what this
festival is ultimately about it's it's
an you know it's part
um a musical performances it's part a
historical
document but most of all uh it is really
you know an event
uh
that that
a celebrated black pride
culture
and a unity
without further ado
here is summer of seoul thank you
please welcome the nominees for riding
with fire rindu thomas and sushmit
gauche
[Applause]
wow
what a joy and honor to be here
um
ever since the nomination was announced
um which is i think a whole month back
uh i've been asked many times by people
differently how are you feeling
um and as stanley and i were talking
right before uh here he it's it's hard
to be excited all the time
uh
i think i've gone gone gone through
excitement
um
joy um
[Music]
overwhelmingness
but a lot of gratitude
and it also made me wonder
you know it's it's such a big honor it's
something monumental that has happened
in the 35th year of my life
and i just
i just
found a moment to think
what does this really mean what is
really
my story where do i come from what is
what does this mean
and i was able to trace it back to
my grandfather
who
i used to spend two months with during
our summer holidays
in a small village in the southern part
of india
he
was a farmer not educated
and a man of few words which i begrudged
him for because i expected a grandfather
to be more showing love and and you know
i'm a very showy person so it didn't
happen he would but every morning he'd
promptly wake up at
five and go to uh cut rubber off the
rubber plantation to go to his paddy
fields and it was clockwork
and come back and my grandmother would
be there
managing the house they didn't have
um
a lot of money but they had enough
um
but they were very particular that they
wanted all their children to get
educated my father was educated
my mother came from a family of nine
children she was the first one to go to
an english medium school
so when they got married and came to a
city they were able to foreground
education for me and my sister and that
was really the foundation of our life
um and and and and for things that came
to be and and allowed me to dream
uh find my place in the world uh be
awkward um be
confidently awkward i think uh and and
really find find who i am
through different phases of my life
they've been failures they've been
successes and then i met somebody who
had a very similar history um we met at
film school
sushma's family again grandparents were
refugees
who came to india
with practically nothing but a lot of
trauma during the partition of the
country
and build their lives little by little
and i think
this kind of history this kind of story
is
what built both of us and when we had a
common love for documentaries of cinema
storytelling i think that is what
what really bound us together was
looking for stories meeting people and
really wanting to understand
where where do you come from where do
you want to go what dreams do you have
what defines you
and those have been the really the
protagonists of um our films
people with dreams people who had
sacrifices but people who have something
to give back a sense of hope of building
a better life for themselves and others
when we met
the women who are
who inhabit the universe of writing with
fire
we found
the incredible story of india's only
newspaper that's run entirely by
uh rural marginalized women but what we
really interested were in in in women
who have
practically nothing going for them
except for
hope and a dream of a better future and
i feel that i
i am in love with cinema because it is
it is when all our experiences merge
we all are our own stories and i love
absolutely love how we leave a part of
ourselves
um in a film so that somebody else can
find a part of themselves in the stories
we tell
i'll
i'll try and keep it short and
so so when jessica actually
downstairs before we came up said oh so
you have your speech ready
head went what but i of course said yeah
i just found out
uh which is then not untrue uh and i
walked up to rindu and i was like we
have to give a speech
and she froze because rindu loves
planning
she went into her phone and then uh was
like oh my god
and uh
i said well we'll swing it uh and let's
see what happens and
and that essentially has been in many
ways the story of our lives
uh i
in 2015 so we met in film school in 2006
and when we we made our
degree film back in film school we had a
blast doing it together it was a film
about
a photographer an artist who used the
nude form of his body to challenge
stereotypes around being hiv-positive or
gay
and
at that point in time
it was a film that
was very challenging to make
but
when it went out into india it
essentially created a stir and
opened up many conversations and we
realized we could have a blast working
together and so a year after that in
2009 we started our film company and the
idea was how do you transform
uh the genre of documentaries back home
in india at that point in time it used
to be very didactic academic boring
propaganda
and we built our careers on the short
form
i think the legacy of the short doc is
something that is
vital to non-fiction storytelling and
in 2015 we decided to get married we
were an interfaith couple
and so i remember
we were in bombay behind the taj mahal
hotel which is an iconic sort of we
couldn't afford to go in but we were
outside it was a rainy night and
ironically there was no one on the
streets which is an impossibility for a
city like bombay and there's
tungsten-lit streets
and we were walking and
i just proposed to her
and then she looked at me absolutely
into style going but how are we going to
do this
and i remember
having nothing to say to her but saying
we'll swing it and and then very soon
after that we discovered the story of
kabul here
and this has been a journey
uh that has been
a difficult one uh because back home we
don't have any systems of support for
documentary filmmakers so for us to be
standing here
uh
is historic and in a sense we carry the
weights and hopes and dreams
of not only filmmakers from india but
from our part of the world
and i think this speaks to also the doc
branch
and the opening up of the branch and
essentially what it has been able to
champion
a small stories like ours from a very
different part of the world
but
a film that is infused with the power of
hope
incidentally when i'm looking back now
at the bench mark writing with fire our
row is essentially women who have
championed us and on the ground while
filming for four years
karen who is a co-cinematographer and me
were always surrounded by women
and that's essentially the power of
riding with fire if you put women in
positions of leadership
half the world's problems will
immediately disappear
and i think
i think that's i have no clue
what this clip is going to be about
we've clearly we're clearly behind on
our mails but i hope that you will
encounter
the power of the modern indian woman and
what she has set out to do thank you
patrick
foreign
my
[Music]
be
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
wow
i always love this evening because
it's so inspiring
and it's really a testament to the power
of documentary film
it's a testament to
the
art of documentary film
it's a testament to the humanity
of documentary film uh
and
i wanna end the evening
by quoting a
good friend of mine the late
great
um desmond tutu
who passed away this year
and
desmond
says the humanity my humanity is bound
up in yours
we can only be human together
these films
these ten films
are a testament to our humanity and i
want to congratulate all the filmmakers
for this incredible work they've done
thank you all for coming
and
can all the filmmakers
the nominees join us on stage
for a class
[Applause]
this
photo
thank you for coming to oscar week
documentaries please look out for an
email with a survey we would love to
hear from you and your responses help us
obtain grants which fund programs like
oscar week
[Applause]
there was a guy
yes
you